Democrats pounced on Joe Biden after he
talks about working with segregationist
senators Democrats pushed slavery
reparations in the run-up to 2020 and
Chuck Todd runs afoul of the woke
schools I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
all righty so we begin today not with
segregationist senators or represented a
with the breaking news that Iran
yesterday shot down a US drone according
to the New York Times escalating
tensions Iran's shot down a US
surveillance drone early on Thursday
according to both nations the nations
differed on the crucial issue of whether
the aircraft had violated Iranian
airspace in the latest escalation in
tensions that have raised fears of war
between the two countries
I do love again the sort of cycle of
violence language that is used by the
New York Times it's just the latest
escalation in tensions generalized
tensions out there in the universe that
raised fear of war actually it's just
that Iran keeps bombing things and like
shooting things down the United States
has taken no aggressive military action
against Iran as in none going all the
way back to the Obama administration
when the Iranians were taking prisoner
American soldiers Iranian officials said
that the drone was over Iran the
American military denied that each side
accused the other of being the aggressor
obviously we should take the Iranian
contentions with all the all of the
verifiable I think truth that they
deserve I think I think we should we
should absolutely take Iran's
contentions seriously because they never
lie about these things like wanting to
develop nuclear weapons or bombing ships
or anything supporting terrorists
they're perfectly honest obviously we
should take the contentions of the
American government and the Iranian
government with exactly the same amount
of seriousness both of the country said
the downing occurred at 4:05 Iranian
time on Thursday 7:35 p.m. on Wednesday
in Washington the drone was shot down by
an Iranian surface-to-air missile system
while operating an international
airspace international airspace over the
Strait of Hormuz according to US CENTCOM
again the Strait of Hormuz is the
geographic region that is the source of
a lot of this tension right now because
the Iranians are effectively seeking to
bottleneck all oil traffic through the
Strait of Hormuz which is responsible
for an enormous amount of the world oil
market they're hoping to drive up the
price of oil artificially by preventing
a solid supply through the Strait of
Hormuz the United States said this was
an unprovoked attack on a US
surveillance at an international
airspace an Iranian attack on an
American aircraft even an unmanned drone
adds a potential flashpoint to the
growing list of recent clashes
also the White House had late-night
meetings yesterday Sarah how can be
Sanders told news outlets that the
president had been briefed on the
missile attack and that the
administration was monitoring the
situation and then President Trump went
on Twitter this morning and he tweeted
out Iran made a very big mistake so if
we end up going to war on the basis of a
tweet I'll say it's not ideal like we
used to have a procedure for this where
you went to Congress for permission to
go to war and all of this sort of thing
but it is a little funny
downside not constitutional upside kind
of hilarious I mean that Quentin
Tarantino kind of this is like old
school Clint Eastwood you can just eat
Trump growling to himself Iran made a
very big mistake they and then it's just
the bombs launch in five minutes okay so
are we actually going to get into a
shooting war with Iran I think that is
very very unlikely the fact is that that
is the last thing the Iranians won't
forget about what we want the last thing
that the Iranians want is a full-scale
shooting war with the United States the
fact is we could just sink their
military the way that we did the the
Iranian military back during operation
praying mantis but in Ron's continual
escalation of affairs is going to lead
at some point to the United States
having to take some sort of action here
and it's not going to be economic action
so that's not going to devolve into a
full-scale shooting war it's funny
because the press seems to think that
every time the United States fires a
shot that the sense in World War two
that is not the case you know many times
the United States has fired missiles
into particular areas you know I mean we
did it under Trump to Syria like two
years ago it didn't devolve into a
full-scale war between Syria and the
United States and we have American
troops in Syria right now so you know
I'm skeptical of the claim that the
Trump administration is ready to send
150,000 200,000 American troops into the
middle of the Middle East that is just
not something that is really on the
table so we'll keep an eye on that
obviously and we'll keep an eye on
president Trump's Twitter feed to
determine if he decides to announce any
targets via Twitter I guess that's how
we're doing this thing now we're just
gonna wait and he's gonna be like yeah I
tell his beach house yeah and we'll find
out ma'am okay me
while Joe Biden they're coming for all
of Joe so I've been predicting this
since the day that Joe Biden decided
that he was going to run for president
is that all the guns would turn on old
Joe and I have to admit if old Joe had
not spent the last few years being just
a terrible politician then I'd feel a
lot more sympathy for him because the
attacks on Joe Biden today are
extraordinarily unfair I mean just in
all intellectual honesty they are really
really unfair attacks on Joe Biden now
here's the thing Joe Biden has expressed
sympathy for segregationist senators in
the past Joe Biden has actually said
nice things about segregation and
senators in the past not because they
were segregationist per se but because
he says lots of nice things about lots
of senators because he was wait for it
in the Senate this is just something
that happens in the Senate there are
lots of people in Congress who praise
each other on a regular basis but now
this is just terrible how dare Joe Biden
suggests that he was once civil to
people with whom he radically disagrees
and and again this is as I say it's not
unusual Steve Kornacki who works over at
NBC News national political
correspondent he points out that Ted
Kennedy used to talk about his warm
collegial relationship with James
Eastland the senator at issue in Joe
Biden's comments does that mean that
that that Ted Kennedy was a vicious
brutal racist is that what's going on
there I really don't think so
nonetheless Joe Biden stepped in it
because you're not allowed to
acknowledge the humanity of people who
you disagree with even people who you
think are truly wrong about everything
in hold evil principles you're not
allowed to acknowledge their humanity or
acknowledge that if you sit in the
Senate with them and sometimes you have
to make deals with them that's very bad
not allowed to do that instead you have
to virtue signal at every turn and not
good things done in the Senate
I suppose so here is what happened to
break it down so joe biden was speaking
at a fundraiser at the Carlyle Hotel in
New York City on Tuesday night and he
stressed the need to be able to reach
consensus under our system and he
specifically talked about serving with
the late Senators James Eastland of
Mississippi and herman talmadge of
georgia both Democrats who were staunch
opponents of desegregation Eastland was
the powerful chair of the Senate
Judiciary Committee when Biden entered
the chamber in 1973 Biden said I was in
caucus with James O Eastland he never
called me boy he always called me son
and he called Talmadge one of the
meanest guys I ever knew you go down the
list of all these guys he said well
guess what at least there was some
civility we got things done we didn't
agree on much of anything we got things
done we got it finished but today you
look at the other side and you're the
enemy not the opposition the enemy we
don't talk to each other anymore
oh so this is enough to ruin Joe Biden I
mean they are coming for him and they
are coming with pitchforks they're
coming with pitchforks I'll get to
exactly the angle of attack in one
second first in geopolitical instability
news Iran is obviously escalating
tensions in the Middle East they
announced this week that they're gonna
break the uranium stockpile limit they
agreed to under the nuclear deal it's
not a coincidence that gold prices have
been steadily rising since Iran was
bombing tankers that's not a coincidence
because I've been telling you for the
past four years gold is a safe haven
against uncertainty when people feel
chaos in the wind they start to buy gold
can you afford another hit to your
retirement like the last downturn when
the S&P dropped 50% the company I trust
with precious metal purchases is Birch
gold group right now thanks to a
little-known IRS tax law you can even
move that IRA or eligible 401k into an
IRA backed by physical gold and silver
it's perfect for people who want to
protect their hard-earned retirement
savings from any future geopolitical
uncertainty look back historically when
the bottom falls out of everything else
Gold tends to safeguard savings so go
contact Birch gold group right now get a
free information kit on physical
precious metals see if diversifying into
gold and silver makes sense for you this
comprehensive 16 page kit reveals how
gold and silver can protect your savings
how you can legally move that IRA or
401k out of stocks and bonds into a
precious metals IRA if that's something
you're interested in to get that no-cost
no-obligation kit text Ben - 47 47 47
again text Ben - 47 47 47 that's my name
- 47 47 47 for the informational kit on
investing in precious metals ok so Joe
Biden had the gall the temerity to
suggest that if you really dislike
somebody if you help principle is
different from somebody else if you
didn't agree with somebody you still had
to get things done in the Senate this is
very bad you're not allowed to say that
in the modern Democratic Party and so it
was whoops colds activate now this is
all cynical we all know how cynical this
is Joe Biden was not saying that the
segregationist principles of these
senators were good he's not saying that
these were good wonderful
there's no evidence that he said that
about these guys instead he said that we
tried to be civil and we achieved
civility and we worked together I
thought for a second that that was what
politics was all about actually but no
it turns out that politics is more about
showing that you hate somebody more than
then the other guy hates that person so
all of the Democrats in the 2020 race
jump on Joe Biden specifically this is a
rich vein for them because Joe Biden is
doing exceedingly well with black voters
right now he's doing great with black
voters right now and so there are a
bunch of candidates ranging from Kamala
Harris to Cory Booker specifically Cory
Booker who really needs a lot of black
support if he's going to start climbing
in the polls he's got no white support
at this point Elizabeth Warren jumping
into the phrase won't Bernie Sanders
jumping into the fray everybody jumping
on Joe Biden with the suggestion that
what like he's too friendly toward
segregation that Joe Biden is so couple
questions on this one if Joe Biden was
truly friendly toward segregation why
didn't anybody in the media notice this
for you know the eight years when he was
vice president under a black president
why didn't nobody notice this because it
turns out that Joe Biden has bragged
before on national television that he
comes from a slave state for example he
did this back in 2007 I believe why
exactly didn't anybody notice this it's
not weird weird how the media are
finally starting to pay attention to Joe
Biden's odd musings on race I mean this
is old stuff but hadn't heard this
surfaced until Democrats decided hey
wait a second we have some questions
about old Joe isn't it odd how he only
find out that beta O'Rourke was part of
a hacking group and is also a giant
weirdo with no political abilities as
soon as he stops running against Ted
Cruz isn't it weird that we only find
out that Joe Biden is apparently a
weirdo on race as soon as he starts
running against a bunch of Democrats the
media liked better than Joe Biden hmm
it's as though there's an agenda at work
mm-hmm
here's Joe Biden flashback what kind of
a chance with a northeastern liberal
like Joe Biden stand in the South if you
were running in Democratic primaries
against southerners like Mark Warner and
John Edwards better than anybody else
and you don't know my state my state was
a slave state my state is a border state
my state is the eighth largest black
population in the country my state is
anything from a northeast liberal state
you probably shouldn't drop at the very
beginning that it was a slave state as
like a thing that you are you're
bragging about that's not like a good
thing actually but obviously he's not
saying that it being a slave state was a
good thing and this is the thing when
Joe Biden was on the good side of the
media everybody sort of took his words
for him just being an idiot and him
gaffing and now everybody is taking it
as though he is a borderline vicious
racist and then they're using plausible
deniability so this was the strategy of
Cory Booker who came out and effectively
suggested that he was a racist and then
when to his crying room and hid as soon
as Joe Biden called him on it so Cory
Booker put out a statement about Joe
Biden he said you don't joke about
calling black men boys men like James O
Eastland used words like that and racist
policies that accompanied them to
perpetuate white supremacy and strip
black Americans who are very humanity
Vice President Biden's relationships
with proud segregationist are not the
model for how we make America a safer
and more inclusive place for black
people and for everyone I have to tell
Vice President Biden as someone I
respect he is wrong for using his
relationships with Eastland and Talmadge
as examples of how to bring our country
together and frankly I'm disappointed he
hasn't issued an immediate apology for
the pain his words are dredging up for
many Americans he should so Cory Booker
goes out and attacks Biden and he's
effectively calling him a racist
I know Cory Booker then claims no no I
wasn't calling him race so then what are
you complaining about
like really what's the complaint if
you're not suggesting that he is a
closeted segregationist or has closeted
segregationist sympathies or that he's
treating segregation and segregationists
with too kind a hand and that that has
nothing to do with racism then what
exactly is the complaint pretty obvious
what the complaint is it's pretty
obvious what cory booker is doing here
and the rest of the democratic
candidates it is deeply cynical it's
really really cynical we can see Joe
Biden's response what the rest of the
Democrats had to say about this what
exactly they're trying to do and why Joe
Biden frankly is suffering from a bit of
shrine Freud he kind of deserves it I'll
get to that in just one second first
rings mission is to make neighborhood
safer so you know that I care deeply
about the safety of my house and my
neighborhood I mean the FBI arrested
somebody like two months ago for trying
to threaten to kill my family and me so
I am very concerned with neighborhood
safety you might already know about
rings smart video doorbells and cameras
that protect millions of people
everywhere ring helps you stay connected
to your home anywhere in the world so if
there's a package delivery
or a surprise visitor you'll get an
alert you'll be able to see here and
speak to them all from your phone that's
thanks to HD video and two-way audio
features on ring devices again I love my
ring devices we have them on our front
gate as a listener you have a special
offer on a ring starter kit available
right now with a video doorbell and a
motion-activated floodlight cam the
starter kit has everything you need to
start building that ring of security
around your home make your home more
safe and more secure just go to ring.com
slash man that's ring.com slash men you
don't need to be a prominent political
commentator to want your house to be
more secure and the fact is that many
people who are attempting to break and
enter will ring the doorbell to see if
your home first ring prevents that they
ring the doorbell it goes right to your
phone you can answer it go to ring.com
/ Ben that's ring calm / Ben and get
that starter kit everything you need to
build that ring of security ring calm /
Ben ok so Cory Booker comes after Joe
Biden and it's not just Cory Booker
obviously it's also Bernie Sanders who
is fading in the polling desperately
trying to grasp with all of his
socialist mice all of the might left and
the tips of those putting stain fingers
he's trying to grip onto whatever level
of support he still has so Joe Biden is
so Joe Biden attacked by Bernie Sanders
Bernie Sanders with block of wood Chris
Cuomo look we all have to work with
people with whom we have very different
points of view I do it every day but I
think to be singing the praises of
people who were vicious segregationists
is not something that anybody but he was
talking about working with them is that
the same thing I'm not so sure about
that but that's all my goodness okay I
mean that is so I mean Chris Cuomo
actually saying a true thing good for
Chris Cuomo there by the way like saying
a true thing every so often it happens
broken clock is Right twice a day but
the fact that the fact that Bernie said
well I don't know maybe he actually
loves segregation secretly
weird you weren't saying that like five
seconds no one who's vice presidents of
the United States very very odd to see
all these Democrats suddenly realizing
that old Joe is a vicious racist as I
say there's some shorten Freud to this I
mean it was Joe Biden who's calling Mitt
Romney a vicious racist five minutes ago
based on literally nothing because Joe
Biden is just as scuzzy a politician as
all the rest of these as all the rest of
these dolts here is Joe Biden doing this
routine back in 2012
and what they're proposing Romney wants
to let them he said the first hundred
days he's gonna let the big banks once
again write their own rules unchain Wall
Street they're gonna put y'all back in
Chains I said that heard a little black
audience gonna put y'all back in Chains
what a so he deserves everything he is
getting on just a cosmic level but it is
kind of hilarious to watch and and sad
in the sense that if you like truth it's
sad to watch these Democrats pile on
Biden for making the fairly innocuous
remark that a bunch of people he was
taking an extreme example the example
doesn't work if he says you know who I
agreed with a lot John McCain and then
we made deals that doesn't actually work
the entire example that he was using is
predicated on the fact that he disagreed
with someone and thought that they were
bad people that's the whole example the
the left has gone so far that I'm now
defending Joe Biden what have you people
done to me how am I the Joe Biden
defender today because I still care a
little bit about honesty and democratic
candidates don't
apparently so senator Kamala Harris who
is also black and also running for
president and also cynical said if those
men had their way I wouldn't be in the
United States Senate I'm and on this
elevator right now she's talking about
senators Eastland and Talmadge right so
what does that have to do with what Joe
Biden said and then you have Bill
DeBlasio who strangled the groundhog and
then went on Twitter and wrote it's 2019
and Joe Biden is longing for the good
old days of civility typify by James
Eastland it's past time for apologies
her evolution from Joe Biden he
repeatedly demonstrates he's out of step
with the values of the modern Democratic
Party and then in the most cynical
fashion de Blasio tweets out a picture
of himself with his wife who happens to
be black the idea being I suppose the
Joe Biden would have opposed that or is
okay with people who oppose that or
something pretty amazing amazing stuff
now Joe and by the way the most extreme
folks of course are the woke scolds on
the Left who come for Joe Biden Dan
Savage who is just a disgusting human
being I mean Dan Savage is the worst and
in a variety of ways a man so gross that
he once volunteered for the Gary Bauer
campaign in 2000 and because he hated
Gary Bower when he obtained the flu dan
Savage he decided to go around licking
the doorknobs in the office so as to
give all of the other staffers the flu
so Dan Savage who is now the voice of
tolerance apparently right he runs one
of these anti-bullying groups even
though he was one of the bigger bullies
in modern media he tweeted out can't say
you've never had a racist bone in your
body when you were just sucking a dead
segregationist bleep what a kind
anti-bullying guy Dan savages
really really nice guy Dan Savage my
favorite part of this is when there was
an MSNBC anchor yesterday talking about
all of us and the MSNBC anchor called
all of the segregationist senators
Republicans MSNBC has issued no apology
or correction by the way these were all
Democrats still to come
Joe Biden references his relationships
with two former Republican colleagues at
an event in New York City the only
problem they were both segregationist
well there was another problem which is
that they were both Democrats but you
know I guess MSNBC doesn't care about
that sort of okay so Cory Booker says
what he says and he is you know leading
the charge here because Cory Booker is
desperately trying to wrest away control
of some segments of the black vote
particularly in southern primaries like
South Carolina away from Joe Biden and
Joe Biden responds exactly how Joe Biden
should respond frankly I mean Joe Biden
should say he should have responded this
way on the Hyde Amendment Joe Biden's
entire appeal right now is with the
moderate and conservative segments of
the Democratic Party which yes does
still exist if you look at the polls
right now he is extraordinarily narrowly
leading the rest of the field among
liberals it's like 25 to 24 over people
like Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren
okay but when it comes to when it comes
to moderate voters in the Democratic
Party conservative voters he's up on the
rest of the field by a margin of 30
points if he starts to fade because he
starts to kowtow I'm things like the
Hyde Amendment if he cows here then he's
admitting guilt and he can't do that and
he shouldn't do that so Joe Biden
responds in my opinion particularly
appropriately here he slaps at Cory
Booker you're not allowed to do this by
the way according to the media if you
slap a Cory Booker so they have this
catch-22 Cory Booker effectively implies
that you are secretly a racist or two
kinds of racists and then you respond
the way Biden does and then they call
you racist for responding to Cory Booker
here is Joe Biden trying to respond your
Democratic rivals are implicitly saying
that you have issues talking about race
they know better are you going to
apologize like Cory Booker has for what
Cory Booker's call it for it he's
actually to apologize he knows better
I'm not a racist bone in my body I've
been involved in civil rights my whole
career period period period okay he is
right and Cory Booker does know better
Cory Booker is a cynical player a very
cynical player okay there are people who
know him going back to his days in
Newark where he was pretending to
cultivate bipartisan relationships which
he abandoned as soon as he become a
senator from New Jersey
he has shifted his positions on a wide
variety of issues he knows better than
this he routinely castigates people he
pretends to be friends with Cory Booker
Joe Biden is 100% right about this well
get to Cory Booker's response to Cory
Booker then goes on CNN last night and
plays the victim now Cory Booker who
attacked Biden over something Biden said
that actually should not be all that
controversial again I hate
segregationists segregationists are
wrong their perspective is evil they
were also sitting in the United States
Senate and you had to work with them to
get things done sometimes if this is the
New Democratic Party then you know count
anyone of reasonable dint out
here's cory booker being interviewed on
CNN by who's is Don Lemon interviewing
him yeah Don Lemon on CNN and Cory
Booker attacking Joe Biden anew you know
the vice president said I should know
better and this is what I know as a
black man in America I know the deeply
harmful and hurtful a usage of the word
boy and how it was used to humanize and
degrade this is deeply disappointing we
waited for him to apologize he did until
the next day and whether I'm running for
president or not as many people today
have been on Juneteenth no less calling
out for the vice president to
acknowledge that his words were harmful
and hurtful on Juneteenth to know us
yeah you're right probably Joe Biden you
know opposed the Emancipation
Proclamation which is what is what
Juneteenth is celebrating
he's so cynical Cory Booker my goodness
he is he is a he has a rehearse
mechanical cynical guy I mean that is a
cynical dude right there and Joe Biden
has every right to fire back on Cory
Booker and he shouldn't stop firing back
on Cory Booker because what Booker is
doing there he's really really ugly
really ugly by
spokesperson came out yesterday and
talked about this as well points it
doesn't needed done Biden campaign
surrogate and former Obama staffer very
early on in his in his campaign in 2008
and she points out that both Booker an
Elizabeth Warren who also attacked Biden
over this have touted their work with
GOP senators in the past which is all
that Biden was doing here but again this
is a cynical ploy to separate Biden from
a black base of support that's all this
is work all the time with members of the
other party whose positions are
repugnant to all of us as Democrats know
Cory Booker who has worked with Jeff
sessions on many things um Elizabeth
Warren talks about how she's worked with
Chuck Grassley who led the fight for
Brett Kavanaugh and who wouldn't even
meet with Merrick garland and the
Elizabeth Warren tells the story about
how she has worked with Chuck Grassley
for over-the-counter hearing aids to
save money for people the reality is a
housing segregationist views okay so I
needed done getting just raked over the
coals for all this and the media going
out and really digging up as much
material as they possibly can on Joe
Biden now so it's open season on Joe
Biden and again this is all really
cynical all this stuff has been out
there for a very long time Joe Biden did
not say anything here that is
particularly new or groundbreaking the
new implication that Joe Biden is
secretly a racist or the times have
passed him by
it's a cynical invention again I don't
like Joe Biden I think Joe Biden is just
as cynical as many of the politicians
attacking him today what I do hate is
people who are lying and what we are
watching right now are a bunch of people
who are telling deliberate lies about
Joe Biden specifically because they're
looking to open a racial gap reopening
racial gaps in the country to suggest
that America is rife with racism to get
ahead politically is one of the ugliest
aspects of our politics right now and
we'll talk more about that in just one
second first getting fit staying healthy
it always sounds easier said than done
open fit is bringing you something new
it makes it even easier never to miss a
sweat session so I work out like every
day which is why I am just jacked guys
but one of the ways that I get jacked is
that I use open fit because sometimes
you can't make it to the gym sometimes
it hits like 8 o'clock at night and it
turns out that you haven't worked out
that say well open fit takes all of the
complexity out of losing weight and
getting fit it's a brand new super
simple stream
service it allows you to work out from
the comfort of your living room in as
little as 10 minutes a day actually very
often I'll work out twice it takes
that's the kind of dude I am I'll go
work out and then at night my wife comes
home from being a doctor and she is
ready to work out and it's like 8
o'clock at night and so he put on open
fit and we go for it open fit has
changed the way I work out with my coach
Shapiro you can join me on a fitness
journey personalized just for you again
use my coach Shapiro start using open
fit for your journey to a healthier life
right now during the open fit 30-day
challenge my listeners get a special
extended 30-day free trial membership to
open fit where you can lose up to 15
pounds in 30 days when you texture Piro
to 30 30 30 you will get full access to
open fit all the workouts and the
nutrition information totally free again
just texture pro2 30 30 30
that's text Shapiro 2 30 30 30 go check
it out right now
ok so speaking of reopening racial
wounds deliberately in order to make
political hay the entire Democratic
Party is now engaged in this process
they're reopening racial wounds by
talking about slavery reparations now I
think we can all acknowledge and in fact
fought a giant war to acknowledge that
slavery was a grave evil I think that
everyone acknowledges at this point in
American life 50 years after the Civil
Rights Act I think everyone acknowledges
that Jim Crow was deeply evil was a
deeply evil thing I don't think you can
find an American in public life will
argue that Jim Crow was not a deeply
evil thing I don't think you can find
many Americans at all as in like you
might be able to count them on one hand
and they all hang out with Richard
Spencer I think that there there very
few Americans who are walking around
going you know it would be great a
systemized way of keeping the black
person down and like that that is not a
thing in modern America I know that this
is an anthem of the left many folks on
the Left want to suggest that racism is
inherent in American life it's the it's
the stain in our DNA that will never go
away Barack Obama used to make claims
like this when he was president I
thought it was ugly then I think it's
ugly now talking about slavery
reparations which is inherently
unworkable this is the thing about
slavery reparations not a single
proponent of slavery reparations has
ever put forth a proposal that makes any
sort of logical reasonable legal sense
none the only reason to discuss this is
to imply the people who oppose slavery
reparations don't do so on the basis of
impracticality or the immorality of
slavery reparations they do so on the
base
of pure unadulterated racism because
they don't take the legacy of rate of
racism and slavery seriously enough
that's the implication Democrats are
trying to draw here which is why I think
that they were having congressional
hearings on an issue that is never going
anywhere that's why they did this
okay so had congressional hearings
yesterday now let me just point out that
among the brutal vicious racists who
once opposed slavery reparations is
Barack Obama
here's barack obama circa 2008 being
asked about slavery reparations every
single Democratic candidate opposed
slavery reparations in 2008 except for
Dennis Kucinich who was considered a
nutjob because he is a nutjob
here's Barack Obama answering the
question I think the reparations we need
right here in South Carolina is
investment for example in our schools I
did a town hall meeting in Florence
South Carolina in an area called the
corridor of shame
they've got buildings that students are
trying to learn in that were built right
after the Civil War and we've got
teachers who are not trained to teach
the subjects they're teaching in high
dropout rates we got to understand that
their corridors of shame all across the
country
and if we make the investments and
understand that those are our children
okay so it used to be okay to say in the
sort of stuff
it used to be fine to say this sort of
thing no longer apparently apparently
you're no longer allowed to say anything
remotely approaching this if you do this
means you're a racist so I guess Barack
Obama back in 2008 was a racist because
he refused to take into account the
legacy of slavery that apparently is
according to Senator Cory Booker so
Booker who again is trying to make his
bones by bringing race to the center of
the national conversation once again he
was called to testify in front of the
House Democrats as part of his 20/20
campaign that is the only reason he's
there there's nothing that makes Cory
Booker an expert on reparations there's
nothing that makes Cory Booker an expert
on slavery there's nothing that makes
Cory Booker an expert on the wealth gap
there's nothing that makes Cory Booker
an expert on any of these topics and yet
he ends up in front of the House
committee where he basically gets to do
a presidential stump speech about how
America is inherently in brutally racist
I wonder about having the last word what
happens when the last word is no words
when in
silence and I feel a sense of anger
where we are in the United States of
America where we have not had direct
conversations all about a lot of the
root causes of the inequities and the
pain and the hurt manifested in economic
disparities manifested in health
disparities manifested in a criminal
justice system that is indeed a form of
new Jim Crow and so we as a nation have
not yet truly acknowledged and grappled
with racism and white supremacy that has
tainted this country's founding and
continues to persist in those deep
racial disparities and inequalities
today so serious I mean stop him there
that this is such absolute unmitigated
nonsense the idea that we have not had
these conversations and are not having
these conversations
there's a reason timing he coaches
famous guys not because he's a wonderful
writer he's famous James Baldwin is
famous there there are lots of famous
black authors who have written on these
topics for decades we've not been having
a racial conversation in this country
for years truly that's the line that
Cory Booker is going with I'll get to
Tonia he see coach who's also called to
testify because he wrote a very purple
essay for the Atlantic a few years back
about slavery reparations the entire
essay was basically him describing how
evil slavery was agree truly evil maybe
we should have fought a war that killed
600,000 Americans to end it oh wait we
did maybe then we should have spent a
century in the North trying to overturn
the legacy of Jim Crow maybe we should
have passed the Civil Rights Act a very
far ranging Civil Rights Act in the
1960s maybe we should have spent decades
since then trying to construct
government policy to stop
state-sponsored racism maybe we should
have done all we've been having these
conversations I'm GU wildered by folks
who say we have not been having these
conversations of course we've been
having conversations just because people
disagree with you on policy doesn't mean
the conversation hasn't taken place
we'll get to more of this in just a
second we get cetana he coats his
commentary which is very much like Cory
Booker's commentary the idea being that
slavery is responsible and Jim Crow is
responsible for all disparity between
black and white income and wealth in
America and therefore reparations are
necessary we'll get to why this is not
actually factually true we'll get to
that in just a second first
you shouldn't have to choose between
overpriced designer sunglasses and cheap
shades that will not last you this
summer that's why I'm not going to wear
it
thing other than movement sunglasses
they're really terrific you've heard me
talk about movement disrupting the watch
industry now they're doing it again with
sunglasses the la-based accessories
brand has hundreds of premium affordable
sunglass styles to choose from with
their free shipping and returns policy
you can try on as many styles as you
want right from home I have a pair of
movement sunglasses so does my wife they
are fantastic and they don't cost you an
arm and a leg movement sunglasses start
at 60 bucks no pair prices over 95 bucks
so you're guaranteed to find a style you
love with quality that doesn't break the
bank get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
MVM t-dot-com slash shapiro cy movement
keeps growing check out their expanding
collection go to MVM t-dot-com slash
appear oh go join the movement that's
MVM t.com slash shapiro MVM t-dot-com
slash apparel I love my movement watch I
love my movement sunglasses you will to
go check them out at M VMT comm slash
Shapiro right now and join the movement
that's MVM t-dot-com
slash Shapiro okay we're gonna get to
the wealth gap how much of it is due to
historic discrimination the answer some
but not nearly all we're gonna talk
about whether it is the same thing to
deserve a reparation as it is to
actually suggest that a reparation would
be helpful which is kind of a separate
question we'll get to all of that in
just a second first you need to go
subscribe over at daily wire go over to
daily wear calm right now $9.99 a month
you can get a subscription to this show
when you do get the subscription yet all
sorts of goodies including early access
to our Sunday special this week Sunday's
special features the great one Mark
Levin who stopped by for a chat here's a
little bit what it sounded like
autocracy is a bad thing
whether it's practice one-on-one in the
playground or whether it's practiced by
government and that's why I started to
say well I'd like Liberty I like
individualism I like to be left alone I
like to kind of do what I want to do and
if that's the way you think and big
government and the left is not your
answer it's a really great conversation
we cover a lot of ground ranging from
Trump and the 2020 elections you know
the roots of constitutionalism in the
United States we talk a little religion
go check it out the Sunday special with
Mark Levin when you subscribe also when
you become a subscriber you get early
access to tickets for things like our
backstage live event which is happening
one night only August 21st
Terrace Theatre Long Beach California I
really look forward to seeing you there
because frankly
do you think I want to spend my nights
there but if you're there then it makes
it all worth it guys
I will be there daily wear a god-king
jeremy boring who's unverified on
twitter we'll be there Andrew Clavin
will be there Michael Mills will be
there I hope cleaning the seats will be
taking your questions live from the
audience which is always the best part
don't Esther Knowles any questions
please don't
tickets go on sale to the public this
Friday today only daily wire subscribers
get the presale ticket access this is
pretty important because there only 300
VIP tickets available that includes
premium seating photos meet and greets
with each of us a gift from me and more
oh I can't wait to see what gift I'm
going to give you I haven't even thought
about it yet really I need to think
about what you specifically would like
head on over to Taylor wire.com slash
backstage to get your tickets come join
us for this one epic evening go check it
out over at daily where DICOM slash
backstage also do the annual
subscription instead of the monthly that
way you get the leftist years
hot or cold tumbler which you will
vastly enjoy it fills with tears from
Media Matters for America every every
time a subscriber subscribes Media
Matters weeps help us make Media Matters
weep by subscribing over at daily
wire.com since they are spending every
waking hour apparently trying to take
things from this show out of context I
hear you Media Matters I see you there
go check us out subscribe help insulate
us against the stupidities of the
militant left trying to deep platform
shows they don't like go check us out we
are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
already so Tony he see coats also stops
by again famous because he's written a
bunch of very purple books that are
basically bad James Baldwin knockoffs
like I think about James Baldwin is dude
was actually a really talented writer
tonic he C coats I think it's one of the
more overrated writers and muddy
thinkers in America right now I just
think that his thinking is is messy and
muddy and chaotic there are a lot of
thinkers like that at the New York Times
and tonic he's he coats not at the New
York Times also a muddy thinker any in
any case Tana he C coats steps up in
front of the committee and you'll see
him basically wrap everything into a
ball so it's like slavery is bad agree
Jim Crow bad agree also all
discrimination all disparities
discrimination don't agree also some
people have been victimized maybe they
deserve some form of recompense
maybe agree also the only way to heal
our national wound is to do this
disagree he just wraps all of this up in
a ball and then throws it out there as
though this is self-justifying incorrect
okay here's here's Tony he's he codes it
was a hundred fifty years ago and it was
right now the typical black family in
this country has one-tenth the wealth of
the typical white family black women
died in childbirth they're four times
the rate of white women and there is of
course the shame of this land of the
free boasting the largest prison
population on the planet of which the
descendants of the enslaved make up the
largest share the matter of reparations
is one of making amends and direct
address but it is also a question of
citizenship in HR forty this body has a
chance to both make good on its 2009
apology for enslavement and reject fair
weather patriotism
okay so him wrapping up all of these
statistics here you know trying to
suggest that the difference between
black women dying in childbirth and
white women dying in childbirth that
that is a reflection of slavery or Jim
Crow they didn't have slavery or Jim
Crow for a long time over in Europe and
in Europe the black and white birth
rates death during birth rates are very
similar to the United States so there's
just not a lot of evidence to support
all that so basically the argument for
reparations is threefold
it's threefold and there's some and
we'll talk about sort of the merits and
demerits of each of these arguments
because I think that it is worthy of
examination since we
talking about it so number one there is
this idea that there are folks who are
living today who deserve recompense for
things that are done 150 years ago
typically the answer to that is no if
somebody hasn't done anything to you in
your lifetime you do not deserve
recompense for that if somebody has done
something to you now you deserve
recompense to that so I have a lot of
sympathy for the idea that if you if you
are a person who lived during the Jim
Crow South and you were deprived of the
ability to buy a house and at least
there's a feeling that you deserve some
sort of recompense
from the people who are trying to harm
you but you have to have been
specifically harmed in other words I'm a
Jew I didn't get any sort of redress
from the German government for the
Holocaust because my family was over in
America my direct family we had extended
family in in the Holocaust but my direct
family was over here so I'm not anything
by the German government in Holocaust
reparations
if however somebody survives the
Holocaust they get some sort of
reparations from the German government
that makes some sort of sense you suffer
the harm you deserve some sort of
recompense
instead what is being done is to broaden
that concept out to the idea that if you
are black in America just inherently
right now you don't have to show any
evidence that that you were specifically
targeted by Jim Crow or by slavery you
can't buy by slavery cos been a while
and Jim Crow it's hard to say that that
Jim Crow has targeted you when you were
born in 2002 for example but the idea is
that every disparity is due to this sort
of discrimination and therefore a
broad-based solution is the answer
well in a second I'm going to explain
how much of the wealth gap we're gonna
try and estimate how much of the wealth
gap is due to slavery and Jim Crow and
how much is not so that matters only in
the sense that if you are trying to
determine you know whether slavery and
Jim Crow are really responsible for the
entire difference in in economic
performance and economic wealth between
black and white you should actually
examine the statistics that sort of
stuff matters you can't just throw out
every disparity and suggest that that is
due to underlying discrimination also as
a corollary very important to note that
disparities exist within every group
discrimination has happened to a bevy of
groups in the United States people in
the United States are not talking about
reparations for the Chinese who are
viciously discriminated against when
they came to the United States
reparations are not being talked about
for Jews were barred from a lot of the
same places that blacks were barred from
for many decades in the United States
reparations are not talked about for
wide variety of groups that have been
discriminated against in the United
States and the reason those reparations
aren't talked about is because to bring
a history forward and then suggest that
as a descendant of somebody who was
discriminated against you're therefore
owed something by descendants of
somebody who discriminated and I never
quote the Bible but I think the Bible
happens to be correct on the proposition
that you don't make a child pay for the
sins of their parents that that is a
recipe for a society that is disastrous
in in its in its ability to actually
heal wounds but let's talk about the
wealth gap issue so yesterday on my
radio show I talked specifically about
the wealth gap I said some of the wealth
gap is inherently due to slavery and Jim
Crow and much of the wealth gap is not
due to slavery and Jim Crow this
apparently is enough for media matters
to clip me out of context and suggest
that I'm saying that the entire wealth
gap is due to individual choice which of
course is not at all what I said even in
the clip that they use because they're
idiots because they're absolute fools ok
Coleman Hughes who is called to testify
by the Republicans yesterday in the
slavery reparations in the slavery
reparations hearing and he testified
about slavery reparations and then he
was insulted for it here's what he had
to say and we're gonna go through the
reason he was actually called which is
that he's done a very solid analysis
dating back to July 2018 of exactly how
we should view the wealth gap in the
United States reparations by definition
are only given to victims so the moment
you give me reparations you've made me
into a victim without my consent the
question is not what America owes me by
virtue of my ancestry the question is
what all Americans owe each other by by
virtue of being citizens of the same
nation and the obligation of citizenship
is not transactional it's not contingent
on ancestry it never expires and it
can't be paid off for all these reasons
bill HR 40 is a moral and political
mistake thank you
Thank You mr. Hughes but he still has a
right to speak
he's presumptive but he still has a
right how dare he say things I disagree
with says Steve Cohen of Tennessee okay
so the the fact that he is in that what
willkommen who says there which is that
not every black person in America is a
victim I think that's true the left
would like oh pretty much every black
person pretty much everybody in America
to feel like a victim but certainly
black folks in America they would like
them to feel like victims even though
the philosophy of being a victim of
America is one of the chief obstacles to
achievements in America and when I talk
about individual choice and how you can
rise from poverty I think that's a
fairly inspiring message a lot more
inspiring that America owes you a check
because your great-great great-great
great-grandfather was a slave or because
your grandfather suffered in Jim Jim
Crow Alabama it seems to me a better
message to suggest not that your
neighbor in your dorm room at Harvard
owes you a check because of the color of
his skin and the color of your skin it
seems like a better message to say make
these decisions that are good and you
will rise out of poverty so again let's
start with let's try and break this down
so the argument number one is that
certain people deserve reparations again
I think if you are specifically harmed
then there's an argument that you
deserve something the question is from
whom from whom so you deserve it from
the people who discriminated against you
presumably not from their grandkids who
did not discriminate against you number
two just because there's a vast wealth
gap does not mean that that entire
wealth gap or your personal situation is
a result of discrimination on a broad
level some of it is just on average but
that doesn't mean that all of it is or
that your specific situation is this is
how statistics work so Coleman Hughes
who was ripped up and down for this race
anyhoo writes for HBO tweeted out that
it was fine to call Coleman Hughes a C
word a C word C oo n right like the
racial slur this is what Ray Santee
wrote perfectly fine you can call him
that until midnight Pacific Standard
Time why because he disagrees with Tanya
he C Coates as you by the way one third
of black Americans and then Jamelle
Bouie of the New York Times always
tolerance always kind he tweets out will
the Republican members of the
Subcommittee on the Constitution civil
rights and civil liberties have anyone
serious speaking against reparations or
will they just invite Candace Owens to
do her thing again
Oh Coleman Hughes actually is a serious
human who is written a serious analysis
of the wealth gap it's available at
Collett he talks about the fact that the
he has a long long piece in which he
talks about slavery and American
prosperity he says that the factor
offered as an explanation for the wealth
gap is the exclusion of blacks from a
set of New Deal policies designed to
promote home ownership income growth and
wealth accrual after World War two
White's received the vast majority of
government-backed mortgage loans by the
time the civil rights games of the
sixties made those loans available to
blacks it was too late
the crucial economic balloon of the
previous two decades during which
housing values rapidly appreciated an
already past blacks reeling from the
effects of redlining and income
suppression couldn't enter the housing
prices housing market at its new prices
wealth in the form of property and
inherence ah's became a birthright for
whites and blacks were trapped in
poverty Coleman who says this story
though based in truth has been message
has been massaged to give the false
impression that benevolence from the
state is a prerequisite for wealth
accrual they can't even contain some
factual errors it is true that the
median income of white men more than
tripled between 1939 and 1960 but the
median income of black men more than
quintupled during that same period
between 1940 and 1960 the black poverty
rate fell from 87 percent to 47 percent
before any significant civil rights
gains were made also the fact is that
there have been other groups
discriminated against starting with the
California alien land law of 1913 14
states passed laws preventing
japanese-american peasant farmers from
owning land and property the laws
existed until 1952 there's not allowed
to talk about reparations to
japanese-americans over all of that
specifically because you asian-americans
overperform in terms of income and
wealth accrual he says historical racism
can't explain wealth disparities between
groups of the same race either a 2015
survey of wealth in Boston found that
the median black household had only 8
dollars of wealth but the $8 figure only
pertained to black Bostonians of
American ancestry black Bostonians of
Caribbean ancestry had 12,000 dollars of
wealth despite having identical rates of
college graduation only slightly higher
incomes and being equally black in the
same city he says there's a kernel of
truth to the idea that the wealth gap is
historically based but that doesn't mean
that the
act that the vast majority of the wealth
gap is attributable to historical
discrimination and so that's what
Coleman who's writes about and gets
ripped up and down for all this
the second contention of the slavery
reparations advocates is that this is
going to heal wounds I ask you is it
really gonna heal wounds to make white
people who had nothing to do with
slavery pay black people who are never
enslaved like who receives these these
payments Barack Obama who's never had a
slave ancestor who exactly how are we
going to pick this out and who's gonna
pay those Jews who arrived in 1907
Asians who arrived Irish people some of
whom immigrant immigrated to the United
States who fight in the Civil War on
behalf of freeing slaves
like who exactly is going to pay these
reparations how is that going to heal
wounds finally there's the argument that
this is going to better lives and make
lives better I don't see the evidence
that signing an $80,000 check is either
going to heal wounds or make lives
better dropping wealth over folks
doesn't just fix the problem and we've
been trying redistributionist policies
in this country in the war on poverty
since 1960s and the poverty gap remains
and so does the racial wealth gap the
fact is the government has tried to
solve a lot of these problems over and
over again the Community Reinvestment
Act which largely led to the subprime
mortgage crisis was a direct attempt to
address the evils of redlining the idea
was that banks had not been providing
black homeowners and potential
homeowners with the loans that they
should have thus subprime mortgages
would be sponsored by Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac that happened and then you
know what happened a lot of people
couldn't pay those subprime mortgages in
them and the mortgage market melted down
the government is not always the
solution to a historic problem so there
all sorts of problems here now one of
these problems that I am pointing out is
in any way downplaying the evils of
slavery or Jim Crow but none of this
conversation is honest from folks on the
left the conversation is simply that if
you don't agree with Tana he coats on
slavery reparations then you also must
not agree with Tana he see Coates that
slavery was bad and that of course is
idiotic okay time for some things I like
and then some things that I hate so
things that I like today so yesterday
was in G indeed Juneteenth and every
it's a national holiday holiday in the
state of Texas it should become a
national holiday the Emancipation
Proclamation issued on yesterday's date
in 1863
patient Proclamation is a particularly
fascinating document Lincoln said he
thought it was the most important thing
he'd ever done basically he was born to
do it the Emancipation Proclamation
shifted the nature of the Civil War from
a battle about reunifying the Union to a
battle about the abolition of slavery he
was urged by his own cabinet not to
announce it and so after a victorious
battle he did wait until after a
victorious battle and then he threatened
the South in late September 1862 that if
they did not come back to the table he
would issue the Emancipation
Proclamation and then he went ahead and
he did it he said whereas on these 20 on
the 22nd day of September in the year of
our Lord 1862 a proclamation was issued
by the President of the United States
containing among other things the
following to it then on the first day of
January in the year of our Lord 1863 all
persons held as slaves within any state
or designated part of a state the people
whereof shall then be in rebellion
against the United States shall be then
thence forward and forever free and the
executive government of the United
States including the military and naval
authority thereof will recognize and
maintain the freedom of such persons and
will do no act - or acts to repress such
persons or any of them in any efforts
they may make for their actual freedom
that the executive will on the first day
of January by Proclamation designate the
states and parts of States if any in
which the people thereof respectively
shall then be in rebellion against the
United States and the fact that any
state or the people thereof shall on
that day be in good faith represented
represented in Congress of the United
States by members shall in the absence
of strong countervailing testimony be
deemed conclusive evidence that such
state and the people thereof are not
then in rebellion against the United
States now therefore I Abraham Lincoln
presidents of the United States by
virtue of the power in me vested as
commander-in-chief of the army and navy
of the United States in time of armed
actual armed rebellion against the
authority and governments of the United
States and as a fit and necessary war
measure for suppressing said rebellion
due on this first day of January in the
year of our Lord 1863 and in accordance
with my purpose so to do publicly
proclaimed for the full period of 100
days from the first day after mentioned
order and designate as the States and
parts of states wherein the people
thereof respectively are in this day
rebellion against the United States and
then he names all of the various
principalities and states that are in
rebellion he says by virtue of the power
and for the purpose of for assent I do
order and declare that all persons held
as
within said designated states and parts
of states are and henceforward shall be
free but the executive government of the
United States including the military and
naval authorities thereof will recognize
and maintain the freedom of said persons
and I hereby enjoin upon the people so
declared to be free to abstain from all
violence unless in necessary
self-defense and I recommend that that
recommend to them that in all cases when
allowed they labor faithfully for
reasonable wages he's calling for peace
obviously as I further declare and make
known that such persons of suitable
condition will be received into the
armed service of the United States so
he's gonna say that black folks could
serve in the Union Army as upon this act
sincerely believed to be an act of
Justice warranted by the Constitution
upon military necessity I invoked the
considerate judgment of mankind and the
gracious favor of Almighty God now one
of the things that this was really
important in doing the Emancipation
Proclamation was keeping the Brits out
of the war so there's a lot of talk
about the British entering the war on
behalf of the Confederacy in order to
split apart the United States the
Emancipation Proclamation by
transforming the war from the war of
unification a war on the Confederacy
into a war in favor of abolishing
slavery basically kept the Brits out it
basically kept the Europeans out because
they were opposed to slavery and so now
they would be on the side of an evil
institution rather than an aside of a of
a rebelling part of a nation a deeply
important moment in American history and
a transformative moment in American
history that we should certainly all
celebrate it's this is an amazing
country it is I mean we have a monument
to a president who we have a massive
monument to a president who was able to
mobilize a population to fight a war on
behalf of freeing a subject people
people who are enslaved and brutalized
that's an amazing thing and the fact
that the United States has not always
lived up to its commitment to its
highest ideals that does not mean that
the American people have have not sought
to do so on a broad level or that now
the American people are guilty for the
sins that have been committed in the
past if we want to live with each other
if we actually want to come together and
lead better lives then reopening wounds
by grouping people according to race and
suggesting the people who are not guilty
for sins pay other people who didn't
directly suffer from those sins
that's that's a very bad way of doing
this it's an it's unconstitutional it's
illegal and it's and it's negative we
should all be able to celebrate the
legacy of the Emancipation Proclamation
together
frankly okay time for some things that I
hate so it is pretty impressive how
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez has been able to
escape censure from her own party as I
said yesterday I am just waiting for AOC
the estimable brilliant AOC to announce
that the earth is flat so that we can
hear the media's explanation of why
actually she is correct why actually she
is right well it's funny to watch
everybody treat her as a child I mean
other Democrats literally treat her as a
child
so there's one representative who
yesterday was asked about her her
statements that the that the detention
centers on the border are actually
concentration camps like Holocaust like
concentration camps and representative
Henry Cuellar who is a representative
for Texas is a twenty eighth
congressional district he was asked
about this and he explained that AOC
just uses words differently than other
humans her comparison to the Holocaust
and especially ending it by saying never
again well again without due respect to
her she has a different usage of words
and Serna maybe a different perception I
live in the border I've been to those
detention centers have been to those
shelters as you know if they're adults
they're in detention centers but if
they're children they are put in
shelters or run by nonprofits I would
not use the terms that she used and
imply anything else after that she has a
different usage you say she just uses
English differently
remember when Nancy Pelosi said the same
thing about El honimaru head Omar's a
vicious anti-semite and Nancy Pelosi
said exactly the same thing about Ilhan
Omar she said oh you know the thing is
that she she just uses words differently
than other humans I don't think our
colleague is an anti-semitic I think she
has a different experience in the use of
words doesn't understand that some of
them are fraught with meaning that she
what didn't realize but nonetheless
that we had to address you know one of
the things I love right now is how this
new class of freshmen Democrats they are
being treated like my three-year-old son
I appreciate the enthusiasm but stop
running into walls they use words
differently so AOC uses words as two
words differently and so does ohon Omar
she uses words differently this is why
English should be the official language
of the United States mainly so that
people who already speak English should
use words the way that humans use words
that we can understand the words that
they use don't tell me that AOC didn't
know what she was saying she knew
exactly what she was saying and then she
was upset that she said it and so she
lied about it and the same thing is true
even Omar she knew exactly what she was
saying and then people objected and then
the Democrats came to her defense by
pretending that she's a small child it
really is pretty demeaning frankly and
then Nancy Pelosi was asked yesterday
about a oh she's ridiculous
concentration-camp remarks and here was
her explanation it's all Republicans
pouncing everywhere these members of
Congress are they come and represent
their districts and their point of view
and they take responsibility for the
statements that they make I'm not up to
date on her most recent when I saw
something in the news but I am no I
haven't spoken to her about that I do
have some comments to make to my caucus
writ large about the political nature of
how politically charged the atmosphere
is so understand that while the
Republicans have no interest in holding
the president accountable for his words
they will misrepresent anything that you
say just if you have one word in the
sentence
that they can exploit oh it's the
Republicans pouncing is the issue it's
it's penalty penalty penalty Republicans
like a group of kittens
bouncing everywhere pounds funny you
know some of us actually call out the
president when he says things that are
untrue I make a habit of it here on the
show when the president says something
dumb or untrue I will say that he says
something that is dumb or on true I will
say that the president is lying about
things and some of us actually tried to
do this Nancy Pelosi however is
defending the worst in her own
contingent because obviously she is a
political hack I mean that is what she's
paid to do the funniest part of this is
that our journalistic firefighters are
not coming to the defense of Chuck Todd
today so Chuck Todd comes out and he
says yeah AOC is wrong these aren't
concentration camps that's absurd and
he was trending last night on Twitter
and AOC directly responded to him and
now she and the rest of the media are
gaslighting Chuck Todd so I have to
admit that again internecine warfare
among Democrats in the journalistic
establishment are somewhat of music but
Chuck Todd is correct about those after
being criticized Ocasio Court has tried
to make a distinction between
concentration camps and Nazi death camps
where the industrialized mass slaughter
of the Holocaust occurred fair enough
but congresswoman tens of thousands were
also brutalized tortured starved and
ultimately died in concentration camps
camps like Dachau if you want to
criticize the shameful treatment of
people at our southern border fine
you'll have plenty of company but be
careful comparing them to Nazi
concentration camps because they're not
at all comparable okay and then aoc
responds by smacking Chuck Todd sued now
she's just fully gaslighting everyone
she says well Chuck Todd the fact that
you slipped in Nazi when I never said
that is pretty unfortunate you know you
did say it's so funny the entire media
just ignored the part where she said
never again in that clip it's incredible
and she said never again in that clip
which is a specific Holocaust reference
every note everyone knows that's a
specific Holocaust reference also when
you say concentration camp I really
doubt that she was talking about the
long history of the Boer War I don't
think she knows what that is I think if
you asked her what the Boer War is she
would think it's a cooking show about
roasting pork hey this is it's ridicu
says chuck todd is responsible minute
gasps let you die says almost as
unfortunate as the fact that you spent
this whole time without discussing DHS
freezers dog pounds missing children
human rights abuses that uphold use of
this term yeah that's right Chuck Todd
is not concerned enough about what's
happening on the border it's it's it's
ridiculous
I'm sorry this whole thing is ridiculous
but we I guess we have we're gonna
continue with the myth that aoc knows
what she's talking about
the good news is she provides new fodder
for Democrats to defend every day that
is increasingly stupid so she did
another Instagram live and in this
Instagram live I guess this is the this
may have been these was this the same
one she won the same shirt so I assume
this is the same one where she suggested
that the Holocaust was happening on our
southern border in the same video she
also had some points to make about
socialism that are so wildly untrue that
I'm looking forward to seeing how the
media spend them
think about capitalism and they're like
Oh capitalism that means businesses
right that means a free market right
that means that means competing for
having different products compete on the
market right that's what capitalism is
right that's not what capitalism is you
can have free market economies with many
with mixed economies which mixed
economies exist you can have free market
economies with democratic socialist
businesses um what so she literally does
not know what she was talking about like
at all free markets do mean businesses
and businesses competing with each other
and they compete because they are wait
for it free when people say capitalism
they just mean that you can invest in
these businesses that's all capitalism
is but according to her you can have
businesses that are democratic socialist
businesses what does that mean you mean
a business run by the state in other
words subsidized by the state so in
other words not a free market because
it's subsidized by the state don't worry
guys she's so smart she just she's
beyond me I mean IQ points up the wazoo
just incredible incredible brilliance
from this person I'm so glad that the
Democrats in the media have decided to
defend her until the end of time enjoy
this you bought the ticket take the ride
gang all right we'll be back here later
today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow it's a Thursday so that means
tomorrow is the mailbag so you should go
subscribe so you can send me a question
we'll answer it and we'll have all sorts
of fun times I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
20:19 joe biden rounds out his very bad
week with all sides attacking him sparks
fly at the reparations hearing on
Capitol Hill and homelessness destroys
America's best cities finally the
mailbag check it out on the Michael
Noel's show